in this segment we pursuit two themes
every concept has a conditional
counterpart we know about PDFs but if we
live in a conditional universe then we
deal with conditional probabilities and
we need to use conditional PDFs the
second theme is that discrete formulas
have continuous counterparts in which
summations get replaced by integrals and
pmf's by PDFs so let us recall the
definition of a conditional pmf which is
just the same as an ordinary PMF but
applied to a conditional universe in the
same spirit we can start with a PDF
which we can interpret for example in
terms of probabilities of small
intervals if we move to a conditional
model in which event a is known to have
occurred probabilities of small
intervals will then be determined by a
conditional PDF which we denote in this
manner of course we need to assume
throughout that the probability of the
conditioning event is positive so that
conditional probabilities are
well-defined
let us now push the analogy further we
can use a PMF to calculate probabilities
the probability that X takes value in a
certain set is the sum of the
probabilities of all the possible values
in that set and the similar formula is
true if we're dealing with a conditional
model now in the continuous case we use
a PDF to calculate the probability that
X takes values in a certain set and by
analogy we use a conditional PDF to
calculate conditional probabilities we
can take this relation here to be the
definition of a conditional PDF so a
conditional PDF is a function that
allows us to calculate probabilities by
integrating this function over the event
or set of interest of course
probabilities needs to sum to 1 this is
true in the
setting and by analogy it should also be
true in the continuous setting this is
just an ordinary PDF except that it
applies to a model in which event a is
known to have occurred but it still is a
legitimate PDF it has to be non-negative
of course but also it needs to integrate
to 1 when we condition on an event and
without any further assumption there is
not much we can say about the form of
the conditional PDF however if we
condition on an event of a special kind
that X takes values in a certain set
then we can actually write down a
formula so let us start with a random
variable X that has a given PDF as in
this diagram and suppose that a is a
subset of the real line for example this
subset here what is the form of the
conditional PDF we start with the
interpretation of PDFs and conditional
PDFs in terms of probabilities of small
intervals the probability that X lies in
a small interval is equal to the value
of the PDF somewhere in that interval
times the length of the interval and if
we're dealing with conditional
probabilities then we use the
corresponding conditional PDF to find
the form of the conditional PDF we will
work in terms of the left-hand side in
this equation and try to rewrite it
let us distinguish two cases suppose
that X little X lies somewhere out here
and we want to evaluate the conditional
PDF at that point so trying to evaluate
this expression we consider a small
interval from little X to little X plus
Delta and now let us write the
definition of a conditional probability
a conditional probability by definition
is equal to the probability that both
events occur divided by the probability
of the conditioning event now because
the set a and this little interval are
disjoint these two events cannot occur
simultaneously so the numerator here is
going to be 0 and this will imply that
the conditional PDF is also going to be
0 this of course makes sense conditioned
on the event that X took values in this
set values of X out here cannot occur
and therefore the conditional density
out here should also be 0 so the
conditional PDF is 0 outside the set a
and this takes care of one case now the
second case to consider is when little X
lies somewhere inside here inside the
set a and in that case our little
interval from little X to little X plus
Delta might have this form in this case
the intersection of these two events
that X lies in the big set and X lies in
the small set the intersection of these
two events is the event that X lies in
the small set so the numerator
simplifies just to the probability that
the random variable X takes values in
the interval from little X to little X
plus Delta and then we rewrite the
denominator now the numerator is just an
ordinary probability that the random
variable takes values inside a small
interval and by our interpretation of
PDFs this is approximately equal to the
PDF evaluated somewhere in that small in
the Rho times Delta at this point we
notice that we have Delta's on both
sides of this equation by canceling this
Delta with that Delta
we finally end up with relation that the
conditional PDF should be equal to this
expression that we have here so to
summarize we have shown a formula for
the conditional PDF the conditional PDF
is zero for those values of X that
cannot occur given the information that
we are given namely that X takes values
in that interval but inside this
interval the conditional PDF has a form
which is proportional to the
unconditional PDF but it is scaled by a
certain constant so in terms of a
picture we might have something like
this and so this green diagram is the
form of the conditional PDF the
particular factor that we have here in
the denominator is exactly that factor
that is required the scaling factor that
is required so that the total area under
the green curve under the conditional
PDF is equal to one so we see once more
the familiar theme that conditional
probabilities maintain the same relative
sizes as the unconditional probabilities
and the same is true for conditional
pmfs or PDFs keeping the same shape as
the unconditional ones except that they
are rescaled so that the total
probability under a conditional PDF is
equal to one we can now continue the
same story and revisit everything else
that we had done for discrete random
variables for example we have the
expectation of a discrete random
variable and the corresponding
conditional expectation which is just
the same kind of object except that we
now rely on conditional probabilities
similarly we can take the definition of
the expectation for the continuous case
and define a conditional expectation in
the same manner except that we now rely
on the conditional PDF so this formula
here is the definition of the
conditional expectation of a continuous
random variable give
a particular event we have a similar
situation with the expected value rule
which we have already seen for discrete
random variables in both the
unconditional and in the conditional
setting we have a similar formula for
the continuous case and at this point
you can guess the form that the formula
will take in the continuous conditional
setting this is the expected value rule
in the conditional setting and it is
proved exactly the same way as for the
unconditional continuous setting except
that here in the proof we need to work
with conditional probabilities and
conditional PDFs instead of the
unconditional ones
so to summarize there is nothing really
different when we condition on an event
in the continuous case compared to the
discrete case we just replace summations
with integrations and we replace pmfs
by PDFs